[Musik]
hallo herr csl israels was hier ein
bisschen unheimlich aussieht ist in
wirklichkeit zu verlängere ich habe
schoko muffins gebacken mit einer
richtig leckeren vanillecreme und blut
ja das blut habe ich gemacht aus ihm
werden das heißt es ist eine richtig
leckere soße und optisch finde ich die
capex richtig cool vor allem zu
halloween
das ganze sieht nämlich aus wie darüber
fließendes blut hier habe ich noch
glassplitter gemacht aus zucker also die
sind auch wirklich super genial ganz
einfach und es sieht einfach unglaublich
echt aus und da habe ich die marke noch
mit deko artikeln der gerührt das heißt
sie habe ich ein paar messer die rein
geistig habe auch noch monster mit dabei
die sich hier geschnitten haben und
deswegen leiter auch bluten müssen
und die machen sie sind wirklich super
lecker ich habe gerade schon einen
kompletten gegessen und später gibt's
noch einen band wir sind auch nicht so
süß und die schokolade die vanille creme
und die himbeer creme die passt wirklich
super dazu ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
zutaten für die muffins denn diesem
super einfach und ganz schön hergestellt
wird die marines braucht ihr 12 oder
kekse 150 gramm zucker eine prise salz
160 gramm mehl 40 gramm kakaopulver und
viertel teelöffel natron einen halben
teelöffel backpulver zweier 60
milliliter buttermilch und von der 50
milliliter speiseöl
ich verwende da immer ganz gerne ein
sonnenblumenöl weil es einfach
geschmacksneutral ist und wer möchte
kann später auch noch schwarze
lebensmittelfarbe pass zu nehmen und die
noch zum teig hinzufügen datei geht es
wirklich super einfach indem jetzt
einfach die kekse und die werden jetzt
auch noch ein kleiner
ich mach das jetzt in einem
gefrierbeutel einfach zu machen und dann
drauf hauen
die stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite und
kann jetzt hier in einer rührschüssel
die trockenen zutaten verrühren also
zucker salz kann es sein dass man ihn
vergessen haben kakaopulver und natron
und backpulver fallt ihr kein natron
habt können sie ja ganz gerne auch noch
mal die menge backpulver nehmen aber mit
natron gehen die muffins wirklich noch
mal viel besser auf jetzt die zutaten
verrühren
ja das habe ich vergessen vanille kommt
natürlich auch gleich rein mit den
flüssigen zutaten
jetzt kommen die flüssigen zutaten rein
also die eier natürlich mann hinter
extrakt wie konnte ich das nur vergessen
buttermilch und etwas und dies werden
die zutaten einfach noch kurz verrührt
wenn der teig etwas zu fest ist so wie
bei mir es kommt einfach auf die größe
an
dann fügt ihr alter noch ein bisschen
butter münchen zu ihr könnt den teig
übrigens auch mit butter herstellen
dafür müsst ihr aber butter und zucker
verrühren
oder die mutter einfach vorher schmelzen
und dann auch alles mit einem löffel
rühren
mit den dateien schön geschmeidig und
wer möchte kann jetzt noch ein bisschen
espresso dazu geben
das mache ich jetzt auch einfach für
einen leckeren geschmack
[Musik]
jetzt kommen noch die oz mit rein und
werden untergerührt und dem ist einfach
darauf achten dass sie den teig nicht so
lange hört das heißt einfach nur kurz zu
finden und dann reicht es auch schon und
jetzt nämlich den teig und portionieren
mit einem iphone ehre in die zwölf
muffin förmchen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen die muffins in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze ich habe es jetzt ziemlich
randvoll gemacht deswegen lasse ich sie
jetzt bei 200 grad ober unterhitze fünf
minuten backen
und dann schalte ich die temperatur auf
170 grad ober unterhitze herunter und so
brauchen sie insgesamt etwa 20 bis 25
minuten
[Musik]
die muffins brauchen jetzt noch etwa 12
minuten gesehen schon richtig gut aus
die zwischen zeit nutze ich jetzt aber
und macht schon mal das blut also unsere
blut soße und hier vorne stehen die
zutaten für das blut brauche ich 250
gramm tiefgefrorene himbeeren 30 gramm
puderzucker 50 milliliter wasser und dem
saft einer halben zitrone
es gebe ich die himbeere in einem topf
ihr könnt auch im prinzip etwa nehmen
aber in bayern haben eine stärkere farbe
und auch ein intensiveres aroma finde
ich da etwas zitronensaft etwas wasser
zum einkochen und puderzucker
puderzucker nehmen die einfach nach wahl
und jetzt können die himbeeren
aufgekocht werden und müssen dann so
etwa fünf bis zehn minuten eingekocht
werden
bis so eine dickflüssige masse entsteht
und je mehr dass ein gekocht wird umso
intensiver wird auch die farbe ihr könnt
aber auch die farbe mit hilfe von
lebensmittelfarben noch ein bisschen zu
fügen
aber ich finde es drauf mir hier
eigentlich gar nicht untätig flüssiger
das wird umso echter 17 hat auch aus
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr übrigens
statt dem wasser auch ein geist zufügen
himbeergeist zum beispiel das fast weg
dazu oder er nimmt einen halloween
geister
die himbeeren sie netz eingekauft und
jetzt werde ich sie durch ein sieb
streichen damit einfach die kerne
entfernt werden und danach muss das blut
erstmal abkühlen sieht noch ziemlich
flüssig aus aber wenn sie jetzt erkaltet
wird's ein bisschen fester aber wenn er
später merken sollte dass es euch immer
noch zu flüssig ist im kalten zustand
dann könnte es einfach noch mal in den
topf reingeben bisschen einkochen lassen
und dann einfach wieder abkühlen lassen
oder ihr könnt das ganze auch mit ganz
ganz ganz wenig stärker abwenden also
wirklich nur eine kleine prise oder ein
viertel teelöffel damit das ganze ein
bisschen gebunden wird
aber ich empfehle immer einfach das
ganze reduzieren zu lassen
während es jetzt noch abtropfen ich
stelle mal kurz zur seite und streiks
gleich fertig kann ich hier in einem
topf schon mal isomalt schmelzen
die somalischen zuckeraustauschstoffe
ist auch für diabetiker zum beispiel
geeignet und er hat einfach eine andere
schmelz eigenschaft als normaler zucker
ihr könnt jetzt die glassplitter auch
mit normalem zucker herstellen
aber da fasst jetzt eben ganz oft das
nach dem schmelzen der zucker sofort
karamellisiert und dunkel wird und die
so malt hat einfach einen anderen
schmelzpunkt als normaler zucker und
deswegen verwende ich den weil da jetzt
einfach länger christ haltbar bleibt
jetzt habe ich hier einen torten retter
mit einer back folie backpapier geht
aber auch und jetzt gebe ich das
flüssige glas also dass isomalt hier
drauf damit als eine platte fest werden
kann
und da müsste jetzt wirklich sehr sehr
aufpassen denn es sieht nicht so aus
aber es ist wirklich ganz ganz heiß und
damit die glasplatte jetzt schön dünn
wird kann ich das nach hinten schieben
fließen lassen jetzt am besten einfach
runter knallen lassen
so gehen wir noch mal die luft blasen
weg die glasplatte lasse ich jetzt
hinten im esszimmer einfach erhalten so
kann sie wirklich schön fest werden und
ich kann sich später ganz einfach
zertrümmern
jetzt fehlen nur noch die creme die kann
ich jetzt noch vorbereiten und da habe
ich mir jetzt eine richtig leckere
vanillecreme ausgesucht und hier zeige
ich euch mal die zutaten für die cremes
300 gramm sahne 300 gramm frischkäse im
doppel rahmen stufe etwas sonderbar und
vanille extrakt zuerst schlag ich jetzt
die samen steigt reingesteckt in zerbst
lage hier ist die sahne steif und dafür
nehme ich natürlich auch seiner tat und
gibt da drei teelöffel gleich mit dazu
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich die sahne kurz zur
seite und kam den quark berühren darf er
nämlich jetzt eine etwas größeres und da
kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen vanille
extrakt dazu und auch nochmal drei
teelöffel sabbath und wer möchte kann
auch gerne nach belieben noch eine 2
teelöffel oder esslöffel puderzucker
dazu geben könnte einfach die creme
abschmecken und dann schauen ob es genug
ist
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich noch die sahne
unterheben und die creme dann einfach
noch in den kühlschrank stellen bis der
komplette rest auch abgekühlt ist
die creme habe ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt und hier vorne habe
ich eine lokale mit 13 mm durchmesser
als wir können einfach eine ganz große
loch thüle nehmen oder auch eine
spritztour eurer wahl
und jetzt werden die cupcakes damit
bespritzt
[Musik]
zeit zum dekorieren jetzt habe ich hier
eine spritze die mir natürlich nicht
nehmen ihr könnt den q cells einfach so
drüber laufen lassen
aber ich find's ganz lustig vor allem
falls ihr wirklich die cupcakes für eine
halloween party macht und das haben so
kurz vorm verzehr ihren gästen serviert
ist es natürlich ziemlich lustig jetzt
darüber fließen lassen
jetzt können diese entweder so lassen
oder ihr steckt jetzt hier die
glassplitter rein oder nehmen zum
beispiel so eine dekoration finde ich
auch ganz hübsch vor allem die messer
und die mumien und auch die gespenster
und geist verpassen wirklich super dazu
dass ich zum essbarer zucker deko und
dann könnt ihr das messer sind einfach
viel einstecken
ziemlich cool die glasplatte kann ich
jetzt von der folie abziehen
hier seht ihr sie und jetzt könnt ihr
sie gerne einfach zertrümmern
ich nehme jetzt so ein holz dafür ihr
könnt auch einen esslöffel oder auch in
echten hammer benutzen
[Musik]
hoch das glas ist kaputt ihr müsst ihr
nicht so klein sei früher so und jetzt
könnt ihr einfach die einzelnen splitter
nehmen und gleich in die muffins
reinstecken
hoppla
[Musik]
so sehen sie jetzt also aus ich finde es
ziemlich cool wenn ihr wirklich erst
kurz vor dem verzehr die soße darüber
gibt dann versteht sie auch gar nicht
und auch die zucker artikel natürlich
erst kurz vor dem verzehr eingeben
sieht super cool aus vor allem wenn ihr
euch auch so eine einwegspritze ist eine
ganz große aus der apotheke holt also
unserem soll gefragt oh mein gott sally
was macht ihr denn mit den ganzen
spritzen und als ich dann gesagt hat wir
machen halloween videos war alles okay
ansonsten sales bisschen komisch aus
glaube ich so mit 20 spritzen aus der
apotheke zu laufen
aber naja die brauchen wir immer mal
wieder in das geht hier also nehme ich
ihm zu schlimm und ich weiß jetzt auch
diese cupcakes machen möchtet dann
schaut man auf meinem kanal vorbei aufs
ellis - blog.de da steht noch mal alles
ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen ganz viel spaß
und gruseln und natürlich einen guten
appetit bis zum nächsten mal
ich kann nicht beißen man jetzt egal ob
team auf
[Musik]